i'll show this game because it's really
cool
so i'm going to hide the notation so
there's no no spoilers for this game
but nakamura won the game in
11 moves so i guess that's one spoiler
but
uh but he won with black against the
london
against the strong grand master of yani
berev
over 2600 fidei uh this was played
in i think it was a millionaire open
like a rabbit or blitz playoff
and white just completely crumbled in
the opening but it was a tricky line
from
hikaru the apologies for the maybe the
small spoiler
but i haven't spoiled how how white
actually lost so quickly
so um picaro played queen b6 so this is
similar to what my opponent did
except my opponent kept the pawn back so
same idea tagging the pawn
you have this in your london course i do
that's true actually but now i'm i'm
revealing it for free i guess
i haven't shown this in a while actually
um
i think in my london course i show the
move
knight bd2 as an improvement in this
game like played b3
which is in hindsight as we'll see
probably
not great because it's a bit weakening
but knight d2
it's a cool gambit because here if it
takes e4
this is engine approved like white's
considered better
and if stockfish says white's better and
wipes down the pawn it's usually really
good for white
so um i'm curious what hikaro would have
played if if knight d2 is on the board
but b3 development
and then then this move
so car is just violating opening
principles like develops a queen first
moves knight twice to the edge of the
board
but hitting the bishop he just wants the
bishop here
bereave decided that he doesn't want to
give away the bishop hair so easily
played bishop g5
h6 bishop h4
and now nice move so developing another
knight
leaving these pieces kind of sidelined
and now i think this is where
bereave starts to go really wrong but
play as a natural looking move 95 this
is very common in london
lee chess calls it dubious
knight e5 is attacks tonight but as
we'll see after takes
and he may have missed the fact that if
white takes on e5
i'll give this to chat black to move and
win material
so this would be a blunder
how can black just win a clean piece
good job thais k and oh some so many
other people
saying queen b4 yeah queen before
hitting this
and this a typical tactical motif
when the queen comes here early
so um
of course white doesn't take this knight
but takes other knight
but then black has this move knight g4
and all of a sudden the queen is a bit
stuck
it's blocked by the knight so it can't
retreat
on the diagonal i can't retreat this way
either because the bishop is here
so bishop g3 was played this is the
final mistake of the game
and then
g6 queen h4
i'm pretty sure in this position hikaru
played one more move
and beray have resigned
has to make it one of the quickest grand
master london defeats like when white
loses playing the london of all time
maybe i don't know
at least in like a serious over the
board competition
so uh black to move how do you make a a
strong grand master design
in this position
decent number of people saying g5 which
almost traps the queen but g5 there's
queen here
and then it's hard to trap the queen
because if knight moves back you
you escape the bishop here you can't
easily move here without losing the
knight
so g5 is not the move
uh but looks like most people saying
bishop g7 which is a correct move
while this move is usually played just
to like develop and castle
it's also played to threaten to
effectively trap the queen
and white has no good way to
save the queen without losing material
uh sobriety have just resigned here
so 11 moves bishop g7 resigns
he could have played on i think he could
have played bishop
here but stockfish already giving -6
because takes takes some lights down a
pawn there's issues along this diagonal
this would be very unpleasant to play
against recaro
wait king d2
yeah white's just toast especially at a
gm level
so anyway that's um that's kind of a
cool game something that
is useful to know especially the
caligram master loses so quickly
against the london um
and that might be youtube worthy i don't
think i've shown this
specific game for a youtube video before
so
if this goes on youtube i don't know how
i'll do it maybe i'll include the
previous game
um or maybe this will be a standalone
video
but uh yeah how hicaro crushed
a grand master's london winning in
11 moves so hi youtube
yet again say hi to twitch chat
thank you people subbing with prime
yeah the and the reminder for youtube
people if you have amazon prime
you can subscribe for free i do
appreciate when people uh
do that to support the channel um i've
been seeing more people like subscribe
with prime even when i'm not streaming
which is
is kind of friendly or very friendly